actually we view it as a huge
responsibility you can imagine a kid who
in a village in Africa or in a slum in
Calcutta who gets access to a low-cost
phone or tablet device that in five or
ten years will be everywhere I like to
think for every Albert Einstein we found
how many of them we didn't find how many
of them got squandered because they
didn't learn to read they didn't get an
education etc etc so you know imagine if
we could increase by an order of
magnitude by a factor of ten the number
of Albert Einstein's in the world the
number of people who can do cancer
research the number of people who could
think about alternative energy this
could be a force multiplier like like
with like we've never seen so it's very
exciting do you think videos can replace
learning in a classroom I think if
learning in a classroom is about
information dissemination and some of
the classrooms that we all grew up in
was about that videos can do that in
some ways we just can because it's more
bite-sized it's on demand but I don't
think that means that the physical
classroom goes away I think it's a huge
opportunity to allow the physical
classroom to move up the value chain so
if students are able to get their
information at their own time and pace
if they're able to practice and get
feedback at their own time and pace the
physical classroom can now be used for
real human interaction the critics have
said the videos can be repetitive it's
like drilling I'm the last person to
force videos on anyone I'll be the first
to say I think the videos are the least
important part of your education
experience way I view it is if you need
an explanation it's great to be able to
look it up but the real learning is
going to happen when you engage in
exercises and then when you go into a
physical classroom having dialogue doing
projects having a getting feedback from
your peers the teacher can can be the
human in the child's life and sit next
to them and really intervene get to know
them better figure out not just what the
content gaps are but where the one of
their emotional needs what's going on at
home and there's this whole body of
research that if you have a growth
mindset then you realize that no your
brain is trainable that if you just push
yourself and stay out of your comfort
zone you can make yourself smarter so to
speak